The Marvels have landed.
The first teaser for the newest MCU adventure,
which brings together Carol Danvers, Monica
Rambeau, and Kamala Khan, is packed with treats
for fans with keen eyes.
The internet at large's fascination with cat
videos is proof that a cute feline is often
a welcome addition to anything.
Make the cat an eldritch tentacle abomination,
and suddenly, one has the fearsome creature
known as a Flerken.
Though these beings appear to be simple house
cats, Flerkens are actually incredibly intelligent
and contain pocket dimensions that allow them
to hide their deadly tentacles.
"The cat?"
"This isn't what you're afraid of, is it?"
"That's not a cat."
The species was originally introduced to the
MCU in "Captain Marvel" by way of Goose, whom
nobody initially realizes is an alien.
But it soon becomes apparent how dangerous
these creatures are.
In the teaser trailer for "The Marvels," Kamala
is quickly introduced to Goose's true nature,
much to her horror.
For fans of "Captain Marvel," it's great to
see Goose back in action, but it also appears
that there might be an entire litter of Flerken
kittens running about, which is an adorable
yet terrifying prospect for any foe.
It will be fascinating how these deceptive
and cunning creatures fit into the movie's
greater plot.
From Mar-Vell's laboratory to the Kyln, the
MCU's characters love to visit space-based
facilities whenever the opportunity presents
itself.
And with "The Marvels" set to explore the
cosmos, the franchise is adding a space station
to the mix.
The opening moments of the "Marvels" teaser
trailer take place on the SABER Space Station,
which looks a whole lot like the comics headquarters
of SWORD, the Sentient World Observation and
Response Department, SHIELD's space-based
counterpart.
In the MCU, Monica Rambeau's mother, Maria,
founded SWORD, and Monica served as a SWORD
agent in "WandaVision."
The MCU acronym is slightly different from
the comics, with the "W" standing for "Weapon."
With the Skrulls set to play a major role
in the future of the MCU, it's entirely possible
that the SABER Space Station will be used
to explore their corner of the galaxy.
For now, the station's purpose is unknown,
although Kamala does wonder…
"Is this an Avengers test?"
Although one might assume that "The Marvels"
will showcase three different variations of
the same powers, each character has a unique
set of skills that are born from their specific origins.
Carol gains hers from exposure to an experimental
energy source, Kamala gets hers from a bangle
in combination with her alien heritage, and
Monica's powers come from repeated forays
across Wanda Maximoff's energy barrier around
Westview in "WandaVision."
Kamala can create hard light constructs and
Carol can harness a powerful galactic power source.
Monica, meanwhile, explains that she can manipulate
light energy, which allows her to project
energy blasts as well as become intangible.
Considering her comic book counterpart, who
is sometimes called Photon, is able to control
energy on the entire electromagnetic spectrum,
Monica stands to develop even more powers
over the course of "The Marvels."
Either way, she's sure to be a powerful hero.
Making use of alien technology is a recurring
trend for SHIELD.
From the very first "Avengers" movie, it becomes
apparent that Earth is hopelessly outgunned
and outmatched on an intergalactic scale.
So Nick Fury has no qualms with scavenging
weapons research from HYDRA or experimenting
on the Tesseract to develop a powerful new
energy source that would better defend Earth
from alien invasions and interdimensional
warlords.
At the beginning of the teaser trailer for
"The Marvels," Monica reports on her proximity
to the perimeter of a Jump Point, which shows
that Earth is experimenting with jump technology.
This type of technology is featured predominantly
in the "Guardians of the Galaxy" franchise,
and it is the means by which space-faring
beings travel quickly across the universe.
Although the Jump Point shown in the teaser
trailer doesn't seem to be nearly as refined
or advanced as the Universal Neural Teleportation
Network depicted in "Guardians," its mere
appearance implies that Earth is quickly catching
up to the rest of the universe.
Considering the sheer number of aliens who
have interacted with Earth over the past decade
or so, it makes perfect sense as to why SHIELD
and Fury would want to learn as much as they
can as quickly as they can.
Whether or not Earth develops this technology
independent of outside influence is anybody's
guess, but it is reassuring that humanity
is rapidly advancing.
2023 is looking to be a big year for Nick
Fury.
The superspy and former Director of SHIELD
seems to be getting cozy up in space, but
his eye patch may signal when "The Marvels"
takes place in the MCU timeline.
In late March 2023, Vanity Fair dropped a
piece on "Secret Invasion" in which Jackson
said his character sheds the iconic eye patch
in the Disney+ series as part of his character
development, making it seem like the accessory
will become a relic of the past.
However, in "The Marvels" teaser trailer,
Fury is still wearing his eye patch, meaning
that the sequel almost certainly takes place
before the events of "Secret Invasion" in
the MCU timeline.
Marvel Studios' most recent release, "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania," is the latest
event in the MCU timeline, with "Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever" before it and "Thor: Love
and Thunder" in the timeline before that.
Presumably, "The Marvels" will take Ant-Man's
place as the most recent MCU entry, though
it does also seem to take place at least partially
immediately after the "Ms. Marvel" Disney+ series.
It seems like Marvel planned for "The Marvels"
to come out before "Secret Invasion," or at
least at roughly the same time.
But that's not the case.
"Secret Invasion" debuts June 21, while "Marvels"
is slated for November 10, after being pushed
back from a July release.
That said, neither story is likely to suffer
because of the shakeup in the release schedule.
But it will be interesting to see a grizzled
Nick Fury taking on the Skrulls before teaming
up with the light-hearted Kamala Khan in "The
Marvels."
That's assuming Nick Fury in the trailer actually
is the real Nick Fury, and not a Skrull, like
in "Spider-Man: Far From Home."
When it comes to Fury, all bets are off.
One of the mechanisms that brings the heroes
together in "The Marvels" is a mysterious
process that causes Ms. Marvel, Monica, and
Captain Marvel to switch places whenever one
of them powers up.
At one point, Monica explains that their powers
are somehow intrinsically connected.
"OK, so, our powers are entangled."
This place-swapping team-up was teased long
ago at the very end of the "Ms. Marvel" Disney+
series, which features an incredibly confused
Carol Danvers manifesting in the Khan household,
being launched into Kamala's closet and finding
herself surrounded by Captain Marvel merchandise.
Now, it's clear that the scene also appears
in "The Marvels," and it's expanded upon in
the teaser trailer, as the experienced hero
tries to take in the fact that she's gone
from battling alien forces to standing in
a nerdy teenager's room.
Kamala Khan changed the game when she was
first introduced to Marvel Comics in 2013.
She's the first Muslim superhero to ever headline
her own comic book series, as well as the
first Muslim character to spearhead a live-action
Marvel property.
She's been a fresh addition to the MCU, especially
in regard to diversifying its roster of superheroes.
The Disney+ series "Ms. Marvel" received heaps
of praise for these elements, and it seems
that "The Marvels" will continue to honor
the character's cultural heritage.
The teaser trailer for the upcoming blockbuster
includes some scenes in which Nick Fury and
Monica Rambeau visit Kamala's family and explain
how their powers are entangled with those
of their daughter.
The footage makes it clear that the Khan family
will play a key part in the movie, suggesting
that the franchise will continue to illustrate
the importance of her cultural background
and how it influences her as a superhero as
she matures.
When news broke of Zawe Ashton joining "The
Marvels," Marvel Studios shrouded her role
in their typical secrecy, only revealing that
she's playing the movie's villain.
A press release from Marvel accompanying the
teaser trailer confirmed that her character
is an all-but-unknown one from the comics:
a gender-swapped version of the Kree General
Dar-Benn.
In the teaser trailer, we see her surrounded
by an army of Kree soldiers, carrying a staff
oddly reminiscent of Ronan the Accuser's weapon
in "Guardians of the Galaxy" — more on that
in a bit! — and with a female Accuser trailing
her.
If Dar-Benn's name doesn't immediately ring
a bell, that's to be expected, as the general
is a relatively obscure character from Marvel
Comics.
There's not much to know about Dar-Benn other
than he's a general who became an emperor
for the Kree Empire.
The villain seems like the perfect sort of
obscure character for the studio to bring
into the MCU, since there's lots of room for
reimagining Dar-Benn to suit the needs of
the story.
Speaking of characters carrying interesting
staffs, the teaser trailer for "The Marvels"
shows Carol Danvers getting a weapon of her
own, when we see our titular superhero group
facing off against an antagonist who appears
to be Zawe Ashton's Dar-Benn.
Captain Marvel, Spectrum, and Ms. Marvel all
sport brand-new costumes, but we can't help
but notice that Carol's holding a staff behind
her back.
Pair that with the shot of her swinging at
the villain with a hammer-like staff a few
seconds later, and it all but confirms Captain
Marvel will wield a weapon in the movie's
climactic fight.
This weapon looks a lot like a Kree Cosmi-Rod,
the weapon of choice for the Accusers.
MCU fans saw Ronan wield one in "Guardians
of the Galaxy," and the trailer also shows
Ashton's villain carrying her own Cosmi-Rod,
if it isn't the same one.
While Captain Marvel is generally known more
for energy blasts than melee attacks, we can't
wait to see what one of the MCU's strongest
heroes is capable of with such a powerful
weapon in hand.